hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to episode three of autofocus
i love this series this is like a fun
way to explore the coolest tech on the
road but here's the thing about
reviewing a car that isn't yours you get
it you get to drive it you have a lot of
fun with it you push it to its limits
and everything and that's great
and then it's over it's done you give it
back and you go back to driving the car
you drive every day
which is great and everything but as
someone who has a deposit in for a 2020
tesla roadster it kind of got me
thinking
what's it like to drive a supercar
every day what's it like to live with a
supercar so this autofocus episode 3 is
going to help me figure out exactly that
this is the acura nsx
[Music]
so there's a lot of different cars we
could have done this episode with but
acura reached out with the nsx as a sort
of a everyday supercar and after having
driving it actually agree with them on a
lot of those things but plus it also has
a lot of similarities or parallels with
the roadster now also i've seen a lot of
people questioning whether or not the
nsx is a true supercar
to me a supercar is anything that makes
big trade-offs for maximum driving
performance
this thing does that so a six-cylinder
twin-turbo engine mid-mounted supported
by three electric motors doing 0-60 in
2.9 seconds and a top speed of 191 miles
an hour
makes that a supercar to me and it also
has that supercar price tag but
obviously people who really like driving
who are into the performance and the
feel of a race car that happens to have
a license plate on it
they're willing to pay that
[Music]
but what are you getting well i've spent
the last week driving this car
everywhere every single day so here are
some things i've picked up on driving a
supercar every day right off the bat
number one is how low you are even if
you don't realize it from outside the
car as soon as you get in you are way
closer to the road and everything about
this car is lower and more compact the
suspension is stiffer the front and rear
bumpers are super close to the ground
which means two things one you will now
feel every bump and you'll start to
notice certain roads because they're
just slightly less than ideal pavement
and number two
clearance it's really
really easy to scrape the front bumper
or the bottom of this car driveways
speed bumps they all become a problem
every single little pothole
or speed bump
or anything
like that is a challenge in this car you
might as well just drive like a like a
crazy person and swerve and avoid all of
them because
they'll be more important than you think
later
excuse me sir
coming through
i'm definitely at the
the end of visibility for other cars
around me if you're in like a minivan or
a pickup truck or even a big car
and you look out out your window at me
next to you you're just going to see the
roof of this car you're not going to see
like the entire car so visibility is
important from inside the car but also
from the perspective of other people
looking at you
it's harder to see a car like this that
being said i do feel super planted
and connected to the road
and confident
and
pretty fast
you also pretty quickly notice there's
only really enough room in the car for
the driver and whoever sits next to them
at best basically storage and space has
never really been easy in supercars
basically because they're so focused on
the whole driving part that storage is
basically an afterthought i'm just
feeling like this this very much has a
cockpit type of feel this big center
console in the middle kind of separates
the driver from the passenger if you
have a passenger if not it's just a
backpack and some audio gear but like
you feel like everything is on arm's
reach and everything is very forward
very forward so like i mentioned there's
electric motors in this car there are
two in the front
one in actually at each wheel and one in
the back and
technically that makes us a hybrid but
it doesn't drive like a hybrid for
efficiency it drives like a hybrid for
performance so it's using those electric
motors
to fill like torque gap and fill in for
turbo lag and really get you going up
quickly as soon as you hit that pedal
because that's what electric is good at
but so then with those electric motors
you get a couple different driving modes
i think it's four first is eco mode
where you can drive around completely on
the electric motors
which is quiet and definitely smooth you
can't go very fast before it's going to
want to kick the engines in but then you
have sport mode which is i'd say the
normal driving mode which most people
keep it in sport mode is going to
basically keep the engine on for the
most part but anytime you come to a stop
or get down to a really low speed it can
go back to silent turn the engine off
and go eco again but you might get a
little bored of that like me and start
to drive in more in sport plus mode you
switch over to sport plus and it's a
little more
it's a little more responsive it's more
willing to downshift and give you more
torque
and it will never turn the engine off
and go into only ev mode so it's just
going to be
a little more sporty of a driving
experience
you also hit a little bit of a lower uh
efficiency at that number and the last
but not least you do have track mode you
got to hold down that knob to go into it
which will turn
the performance basically all the way up
and you'll get a little bit less
traction control help if you want to
spin the side out a little bit
[Music]
this thing kicks though
this thing definitely rips
and it's really easy to go fast and not
realize it visibility is another thing
to consider uh in this car i'd say it's
actually surprisingly good because these
a-pillars are so thin
i feel like my front and side visibility
is pretty good the rear is still a
little less than a normal car obviously
but you do have glass to look through
and then the engine's right behind you
so it's a little different but
it's all right
and then i had a couple other quick
observations some you might think about
some you might not like the amount of
carbon fiber here is amazing there's
carbon fiber around the outside of the
car the front splitter the body skirts
along the side the rear diffuser even
the roof you don't really see the roof
of your car too often but if it's that
small this one you'll notice and the
carbon fiber is to reduce weight and
then when you get in the car the carbon
fiber that surrounds you is awesome
especially on the steering wheel this is
honestly probably my favorite steering
wheel i've ever held the trunk like i
said storage is an afterthought on
supercars like that aventador i drove a
couple weeks ago had this little front
trunk which is all right but with all
the electronics in the front of the nsx
there is no front trunk but there is a
rear trunk in the very back which is
actually surprisingly usable so you can
toss a couple backpacks back here like i
usually did you can go grocery shopping
for one or two people i actually did
this or you could theoretically get a
whole set of golf clubs back here that
would be a pretty serious challenge but
it's been done you'd probably still hate
this trunk after a while but it's better
than the average supercar the one weird
thing about it is you got to think about
it's so close to the engine that it gets
hot like the inside of the trunk gets
really physically hot so you gotta make
sure you're cool with anything in your
trunk being 100 plus degrees at any time
you may have also noticed that there are
no cup holders in this cabin
wait for it
all right now there are two cup holders
in this cabin classic supercar but
overall the question most people have
about a car like this is just basically
how does it drive and this nsx is i
would say actually much easier to drive
than something like the aventador that
car was believe it or not sometimes
really harsh in a lot of ways the nsx
here is still stiff and super responsive
and low the brakes are huge too people
don't talk about the brakes as much but
it still kind of keeps a lot of the
things that make it feel like the
everyman supercar or at least make it
more daily usable a lot of stuff in this
car feels like it came from a normal
acura like forget the paddle shifters
and the carbon fiber steering wheel for
a second but like the the blinkers
the hazards
the window trim like the the flippers
for actually putting up and down the
window a lot of things feel like
comfortable and familiar which is good
if you're driving a lot
uh
and it's also
kind of adds to that everyday supercar
feel the infotainment system is easily
the worst part of this car probably not
something you want to feel like it came
from another acura but it still does
that and the backup camera looks like it
came straight from 1994.
but the upside is
it does have both android auto and apple
carplay so you never have to use the
garbage built-in maps plus it has a slot
in the middle console for your phone
that happens to be really snug and
actually the exact dimensions of an
iphone 10 so possibly too snug
also you can't forget about gas mileage
this car is not electric after all then
again if you can afford a car like this
you probably don't drive it every day or
care very much about paying a lot for
gas but it is the most expensive gas
every single time you fill up but you
know what speaking of modes
track mode that's not something you ever
really get to turn on during everyday
driving at least i wouldn't recommend it
there's only one place i'd recommend
using track mode and if you own a
supercar this is one of those unique
things that you can do
is taking your car
to the track
[Music]
all right so this is uh
my first time ever on a track
we're going to do a
sort of tutorial modes and figure it out
the first time and then we'll put the
helmets on and go fast later
but
let's let's see what this is made of
we're in track mode
the fun begins so for this tutorial mode
we're doing a couple laps around the
track it's empty it's just me and ari
one of the owners and a quality driver
himself and he's showing me all the
turns the race lines and i'm gonna
follow him and get to know it a little
bit then once i'm comfortable i'll
signal to him that i'm good and then
we'll really move this thing it's pretty
tame
it's pretty tame start up and around the
turn
hugging the inside
coming back out wide
breaking 200 feet breaking 100 feet
break a little okay
i feel like i'm getting it i'm getting
it
i can't tell if i'm a good driver or not
oh here we go he's moving now the one
thing i love about the track road
obviously not only are there no potholes
but it is
super
super smooth
uh you get a different sort of
confidence knowing exactly what the car
will do at any point in any turn
unlike new jersey roads
top of the turn
big sweeper
keeping the outside all right i think
i'm thinking i'm getting the hang of it
right now we've completed our tutorial
laps we're gonna move over
get the helmets on
and uh actually go more than 65 miles an
hour
like way
way more than 65 miles an hour
first lap just get warmed up get back
into it yeah
remember your lines and then
do it
same thing look up through
it's got a good sound to it yeah
and yeah use all the track as you unwind
your hands
there you go
and stay tight for the right
and eyes up it's a good quick life left
and then a quick right
there you go
all right
[Music]
same thing looking up through just roll
through no need for break there same
thing use all the track
there you go
[Music]
just let it coast let it coast
and you feel it start to move around
again
there you go
very hard yep
eyes up be patient be patient
so you feel start to slide around now a
little yeah and the tires are getting
warmer too so they'll start to get a
little more slippery
so maybe break a little sooner yeah
there you go
[Music]
roll back to power
for a tech guy you're not afraid to
throw a car around
all right
i think it's time for me to give this
thing back it's been a good week
i want to give a shout out to acura
for for giving us the nsx for letting me
drive it for a whole week
sorry about the noise and i want to give
a shout out to monticello motor club in
new york who is awesome enough to let us
use the track for the day uh learned a
lot of things this week but bottom line
i do think i do think it's possible to
live with a supercar i think a lot of
people who might not be a fan of those
trade-offs uh might not do it but people
who really love driving
and people who really love performance
and who want to race or drive like a
race car that happens to have a license
plate they're gonna they're gonna make
those trade-offs and i feel like i'm one
of those people
thanks for watching